the Arena in Tulsa Oklahoma where
President Trump will hold a rally
tomorrow that arena is demanding his
campaign provide a plan to ensure that
attendees will be safe from the
coronavirus as Paula Reid reports the
rally will celebrate recovery from a
pandemic that is actually hitting harder
than ever in that state we're gonna be
in Oklahoma and it's a crowd like I
guess nobody's seen before sitting
alongside Oklahoma's governor at the
White House Thursday President Trump
promoted his upcoming rally one of the
reasons we chose your state as you know
Kevin was that you've done so so well
with the covered you've handled it
incredibly well but the city's Health
Department executive director has
recommended postponing the event let me
be clear
anyone planning to attend a large-scale
gathering will face an increased risk of
becoming infected with could 19 the
Trump campaign will be handing out mass
but they will be optional temperatures
will be checked upon arrival and hand
sanitizing stations will be offered
around the building but the event does
not include any social distancing
measures senior Trump campaign official
Mark Lauder has advised those at high
risk not to come the Trump campaign
recognizes the risk as it is requiring
anyone who requests tickets to sign a
waiver agreeing not to sue if they get
Co bid 19 the White House is also
contending with risks posed by an
explosive new memoir by former national
security advisor John Bolton on Thursday
President Trump tweeted attacking Bolton
as a wacko I don't think he's fit for
office I don't think he has the
confidence to carry out the job the
president has a history of hiring top
officials and then when they speak out
against him calling them liers and
disparaging them as dumb as a rock
overrated or sloppy CBS News asked the
president about his vetting process
[Music]
the president did not answer that
question we're also hearing from
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo he has
responded to Bolton's book which is of
course titled the room where it happened
on peut titled his response I was in the
room - and he denounces Bolton for
spreading lies and says he's a traitor
who has damaged his country Gayle
interesting question Paula Reid thank
you very much